mais avant on va vous écoutez quand même
mélanie poquet dans un mois dans moins
d'un mois pardon c'est noël un dernier
mois qui met la patience à rude épreuve
pour attendre plus sereinement que le
père noël se rendent mieux grande pardon
donne ses cadeaux au pied du sapin on va
y arriver
rien de mieux qu'un calendrier de
l'avent mélanie depuis quelques années
la mode est au fait soi même
et oui il faut vous dire grégory qu'en
2015 il s'est vendu près de 12 millions
de calendrier une tradition qui nous
vient d'allemagne à l'époque durant 24
jours ont donné des images pieuses alors
depuis le calendrier a bien changé il ya
des chocolats des bonbons des jouets du
fromage et mène des bières on peut aussi
de créer soit grégory vous l'avez dit on
peut pas varier le plaisir il ya
plusieurs sortes de calendrier ce qu'on
dit le do it yourself de naucelle
alors là aussi beaucoup de choix quand
on a un peu de temps vous pouvez faire
tout le calendrier en créant des boîtes
en cachant les surprises dans des
enveloppes ou des petites sacoches vous
pouvez aussi acheter des structures en
bois qu'il suffit de décorer beaucoup de
commerçants proposent même des ateliers
c'est ce que vous voyez sur les images
et pour vous dire l'engouement cette
enseigne d'activités créatives devant un
millier de modèles chaque année tous les
ans on entend énormément les maisons
facebook ou le calendrier en forme de
triangle plais beaucoup aussi
donc avec des décorations divers des
couleurs diverses
le calendrier peut être mis en valeur
tous les ans et puis les familles aiment
bien les préparer ensemble
alors cette enseigne à en rayon une
dizaine de modèles même nombre de
modèles dans une autre enseigne elle
située à mon amour pas compter entre 15
et 30 euros le support de quoi faire et
se faire plaisir
il faut quand même compter deux bonnes
heures pour aller réaliser son propre
calendrier c'est donc une activité à
faire en famille est dedans qu'est ce
qu'on peut y mettre
lorsque tout ce qui fera plaisir aux
destinataires je ne sais pas quels sont
vos goûts grégory mes parents je vous
propose d'écouter les principaux
intéressés des teams quartier reprises
les choux et les chocolats
des chocolats le chocolat aussi en tout
cas plus que quelques jours à patienter
le 1er décembre c'est ce samedi
merci mélanie le 7-8 durna